so
um
give me a little bit of your background
before we get to your podcast and [__]
like how did you because you used to
[__] like you used to [__] with the
packs back in the day yeah yeah I never
shipped nothing though
I I got one box ready and the guy flaked
and I went this is a sign for me not to
do this yeah
because I like I I spent so much [__]
doing the you know packing it going to
[__] vacuum ceiling yeah triple
vacuum sealing double bag whatever and
he wanted like eight different things I
went and bought them all and he just
stopped he just flaked I'm like bro this
is my sign to just sell packs in person
like I've been doing for 20 years or 15
years so would you just like middleman
[__]
I think everybody's another man the
middleman game is popping in La man it's
crazy I wasn't that guy yeah you know
there's that guy yeah sorry for I'm
sweating my I was just I think it's the
ibuprofen it might be something my bad
um I was about to say you look like it's
a lot hotter in here than it is it's not
you guys are fine I'm just like
I'm sipping hot tea right now I know
damn dude nah like I said they're
sweating like a horn in church yeah I
hurt my back though I think that might
be that might be the thing
um yeah it's crazy because like moving
to La like like just the weed economy is
so wild here and none of them are from
L.A none of them well yeah you're right
I mean are the fools openly and you'll
note and like it's crazy because you'll
notice like a lot of like the plugs or
whatever out here are
there's a lot of Asian folks there's a
lot of Armenian folks it's all colors
it's a wild uh economy in La still that
is still thriving like if you just go
down to downtown L.A
all those high rises are like
let's live in those
yeah it's just like they're just trap
houses in all of them well my thing is
like I'm just glad I'm like in my head I
know I'm a good person right I'm like I
could have robbed you could have robbed
you could have robbed you could have
robbed you pay attention yeah people
through my hallways like you got vac
bags under your arm from Target I'm
gonna follow your [__] apartment if I
was a piece of [__] yeah and what am I
gonna do I'm gonna take all your [__]
yeah all these fools are so careless
posting snaps posting where they're
eating dinner it's like full fools are
gonna shoot you and take your [__] yeah
I can follow you in two days two posts I
got you a lot of these guys want to be
rappers man that's what it is
that cloud is a drug man oh fools are
crazy the best drug dealers I ever met
don't drive wild cars and they don't
have social media facts and they're
still crushing factuals but like um well
like we talked about earlier about
places you know yeah it was like
[__] like that yeah those are the fools
you don't expect the fools that are just
what they're well you said that you had
told so for full discrepancy so you had
you had said that when you walked up
here that you had told a story about our
new location in one of your I don't care
if you share it but yeah in one of your
previous pods I couldn't believe it one
of your story times yeah because I've
heard so for people who don't know
obviously recently we moved into a new
facility in LA
and I've heard this before we got here
we knew it was a dispensary of sorts
right
so when we moved in we had to do a lot
of work we had to fix it up it was the
[__] pain in the ass but I've had two
or three people be like yo man I used to
[__] pull up and get work at your
spot before you had it obviously yeah so
right when I walked in I went huh and
then where I got to the back go oh this
is a nice little air and then that's
when it hit me because I said that when
I walked up like this is a nice spot
like I like that you're not getting in
here without getting shot over the fence
like Christmas Story wow like you're not
gonna make it in here right but right
when I walked in the back I got a crazy
memory
oh yeah for all those fans out there
that watch my stories
there's a certain weed Hub I talked
about and this was it that's when you
said there used to be a wall there I
[__] knew it because it was different
because I remember walking hitting the
right and then he just sat me in a room
where I watched a little square TV for a
while
I think it was
Maury or Jesus or Jerry Springer but it
was only like right TV just out of the
90 out of 96 drug dealer what year was
this was this like in 2014. I don't know
15. wow yeah that's not too long ago
so it's yeah good trip bro yeah used to
be a lot of fire in these buildings
right here 100
um okay so at what point in time did you
start to kind of
pivot out of like full-time trapping
um what happened was that I started
Instagram and uh I thought it was fun
started getting a little following and I
thought uh this is where I go to jail
right be smiling with pounds right right
right right that's just like
that's a dart board and some DEA guy's
office like I like this kid yeah right
because I was supposed to 100 packs like
laying in them because it was fun right
and then I realized like you know what I
gotta stop when I got a homie hit me up
and he told me that these fools were
like all right so you know how you're
going on that trip he's like this person
this person this person already plotted
out how they're gonna come into your
spot
if you leave or not
take you know what I mean like oh [__] I
know these gangbanger ass fools people
were like plotting on you yeah just
because once my [__] got kind of big my
Town's 80 000. this was in Merced still
yeah okay
uh so I just stopped I was like you know
it's not even worth this [__] yeah plus
like everybody in their mom sells
[__] weed now everybody does
everybody back then I'm like
the fools I was giving you peace to now
we're like oh now that I get a pee I'm
just gonna buy it from that guy because
it's 200 cheaper undercut yours I'm like
oh you bastards but my shit's fire but
there was a time where I looked in my
cabinet
and I had like six pounds of forum
cookies I couldn't get rid of it really
and I was like nobody wants the fire
right like no I got it over here for 19
like 19.
look at my heart just dropped like bro I
got this for 27
27. no I gotta get two for 36. yeah if
this isn't gonna work anymore that's all
I thought like merced's too small I'm
done and I just like focused on the
content started to push trees what is
push trees it's my clothing company okay
I started that like uh
2014 and if no end of 13. and that [__]
took off really really really real like
it just shocked me yeah and then I
thought you know what let me just stop
the Wii but I I told my my fiance now
like we're gonna be broke for a while
like are you down and she was down and
we were broke for seven [__] years
straight dude that's crazy but making
content like making content for I just
do it for free I didn't realize you get
paid for sure for all this influencer
[__] yeah so I was just making content
to have fun was this on YouTube or on
Instagram I didn't start YouTube till
like the end of 2018 probably so this
was Instagram Instagram yeah but I'm on
my 30th Instagram account like they they
won't they keep [__] your [__] up
they won't stop so my first page was
huge like Rihanna what it was is Rihanna
would like all my toy pictures all the
time and people would [__] go crazy
and that's how I got a lot of the
mainstream world and not the weed World
watching my [__] and then you say toys
you mean like you have a toy collection
like I do have a toy collection yeah
like so when I walked in went oh I don't
have any anything nice in here
yeah yeah but no I would do like uh I
started off doing movie scenes oh with
snugs and toys oh you watch Reservoir
Dogs yeah of course Marvin Nash gets his
ear cut off yeah I did that I went to
Hobby Lobby about a little chair put a
nug and it's before video so I just took
like collage pictures almost like a
stop-motion almost yeah yeah and it was
just like
Rambo Forrest Gump I just did all my
favorite movies and people just they
loved four hours to do these little
pictures and Rihanna was in she was
lovely love toy pictures and that's back
when like think so and so liked this
post and there was that other page you
can look at yeah
I'm glad they'd remove that me too and
that [__] was dumb that's a lot of uh
people lost their relationships too and
relationships and relationships but we
connect a lot went away right there like
that's the guy oh yeah
oh that's the guy yeah that was it and
then kick came and fools were like hey
I'll sell [__] to you and Vine oh [__]
the Wee World Went weird the Wee World
winner went meme but now everybody's on
like signal and uh what's the other one
got another clue program telegram yeah
yeah I don't know I'm good and uh yes I
was just selling packs I was like you
know what let's go full time on the
content and I was barely making my rent
with push trees so that was enough every
month just to cover my [__]
it was the worst man it really was the
[__] worst but like I was happy as
hell all the time and the coolest job
ever that barely
thank you